Hello and welcome to LWIAY, the first episode with this epic new setup. Look how clean this mirror is.
Now let's go watch memes where half of them is about how unclean my mirror is *chuckles*
Pewds reading: "Do not buy merch here. Only from represent. Help me inform felix about this
Off-brand merch that pops up above the real one."
*record scratch* WHAT?!
You have to go to represent.com/pewdiepie, that's the only place I sell merch, okay???
Does that show up if you search? No, Represent shows up first. Wooow, Pewdiepie classic.... Woooooow, that's soooooo coooooool
Redbubble- it's like the big one that just..blatantly rips off everyone.
Like, the quality is so bad on these prints.
Like, you might think you save money by buying these but they look absolutely unwearable.
I bought one thing from here once and I immediately threw it in the trash... 'cause it was just so bad. Now mOVING ON.
*Pewds reading*
Fine! I just need to trick her. It needs to be genuine, right?
I need to be like,  *Marzia voice* "Hey Marzia what-" That's not my voice
*normal voice* "Hey, hey Marzia come over here" and she'll come over here and then I won't even tell her about the eye tracker.
That's the only way to test if my future wife is gay.
* Pewds reading*
I like that. Maybe we should do, like, a charity stream for trees or some ****. *laughs*
I'm so giving! Maybe we should give us charity for some trees or some ****.
That'd be cool, though. I like that idea. Good idea.
*Pewds reading*
It can't be done. There's a forbidden curse on Poppy Gloria. She will never come back.
Stopppppp. Stop crying!
I've seen this. It's amazing. Did Brad cut this out?? I've reacted to this before! Brad cut this out!!!!
Ohhhh mY gOooooD!
*pewds reading*
Incredible, what did this one say?
"I have a Lego car"????
*pewds reading*
SHUT your fricking pipey- p-
What, is this better? Is this better?? Are you enjoying it more now?
Is it more entertaining now?? In the VR game, you are SITTING DOWN. So of course, I'm gonna sit--GODDAMMIT
*whimpering*
When you disable your comments, you know, you're disabled--you're defeated. *imitating Trish* I haven't even watched it yet. I didn't watch the whole video.
You know it's just gonna be some eat incoherent babble.
*pewds reading*
Still relevant goddamnit. If you haven't checked out Tuber Simulator yet, you are missing out.
Right now, there's a pirate versus ninja event. Check it out. Let's check out some rooms.
I can't record my display, so we're doing it like this.
You can't see it, but damn. So this is the winner...Mogtuber. Look. Amazing.
I lo-It's so crazy how creative people are wit-OHH
*pewds reading*
I like it *laughs*
First time I like the hAmbOrgEr. Hey, look I've seen this meme
Can we bring back happiness and joy to Brad please.
Is there anything we can do...to bring him out of the darkness?
*pewds reading*
*laughs*
Dr. Phil for meme review, please. We need to make it happen.
*pewds reading*
Thank you, Mr. Beast. Very cool. Look forward to the spons.
I like how this meme has made it back for some reason.
*pewds reading*
Come on!
That's probably true.
*reading*
Hey, why does everyone hate Mary Ham?! She's the greatest!
stOp rUNNING oVER mARY HAM!!! *laughs*
*reading*
Looks like Twitch staff isn't a bunch of hypocrite incels. Incredible.
Poppy Gloria's dead, alright? How many times do I gotta say this?
*reading*
Now hold on just a second here! I'm not entirely convinced this happened!
Guys. Stop believing in conspiracies, okay? You're crazy. There's no way that happened.
*reading*
That's a good meme.
See, this is a fake tweet. This confused me.
I was, like, actually worried that this happened, but what she actually tweeted is *reads*
It's the first time I've seen any one of them acknowledge it. That's amazing. Poppy Gloria, rest in peace.
*reading*
Oh my God, that is the best thing I've ever seen in my life.
Six-six, that's the devil number!
*reading*
Well done, Mr. Beast. You deserve it.
Masaka.
reading: "I have several questions." Is this a real picture?
Is that a real picture?
*laughs*
*reading*
You are correct.
Goddamn, well played.
Unban that man.
You wa- you want this? GoDDAmn this is heavy.
*reading*
Gloria is dead. And Mary Ham had nothing to do with it. So what if she's the one that had the gun?
ohhhhhhhhhHHHhhhhhh. That's a good meme. *laughs*
*reading*
Yeah. Looking back,
It's like, it is obviously a big achievement to be the first channel to hit 100 million.
And I-I definitely know we could've done it.
So, looking at it from that perspective is like ugh, but
it was the right thing to do.
*reading*
Did she actually say that?
That is a beautiful photo in paint.
The-- the muscles on Hulk looks absolutely perfect.
*reading*
POPPY GLORIA, NO
Stop crying. She's dead. Get over it. Move on with your life.
*reading*
Fine, I'll play Minecraft!!
This is people literally telling me, "Oh, why doesn't he--not get 100 million views on his videos?!"
That's what you sound like. A dying fart.
*reading*
*laughs* shut up. Shut up. ShUt Up! SHUT UP! Stop making fun of me!
Oh my God, he actually did it. *reads*
Oh my God, look at all those midrolls.
*laughs*
See I don't see why no one likes Mary Ham.
She's like the best. She's my favorite. I love Mary Ham.
*reading*
Good job.
Represent dot com slash PewDiePie! Where you can check out the epic merch!
Epic merch!
*reading*
Oh my GOOOODDD, hurry up and subscribing. I forgooot hahaha. I understand that they had to add the update.
Like, I kind of get it.
*reading*
We'll see. Come on guys!
Hahaha. Gottem.
*reading*
Awww, Poppy goes to heaven.
Come on!
Stop hating on my girl.
*reading*
Oh...my...gOd hahahaha
WHaT????
What??? You never played Tuber Simulator? pshhhh
You know it's fun, right? I'm not supposed to give my opinion
but give it a try, and then you can tell me if it's good or not.
Not convinced yet? Okay, I'll cut you a deal. The game is available for free and that's a great price